okay break down the chiefs game so i'm
watching the chiefs game
and it is i think 23 to 29 with like two
minutes left in the game
chief's score uh no it's 26 to
21 i think the chiefs are up buffalo
drives down the field and scores with
like four minutes left it's 29 to 26
they complete a two-point conversion
chiefs it's like four minutes left three
minutes left whatever it is they
complete a long pass out of nowhere to
tyree kill who's a [ __ ] human video
game he scores a touchdown i think like
65 yards it's like a 12 yard pass and
then he just runs like a [ __ ]
joystick legit
as he's running the ends of the [ __ ]
fast he is he flashes a peace sign to a
guy that's in front of him
he's he's in front of him making an
angle at him and tyre tiger killer's
like that like i got this bro it's over
you're not gonna stop me they score a
touchdown and then in the last
two minutes of that game i think 27
points were scored or something
unbelievable yeah the the bucks came
back down and scored the chief scored
again and the the bucks i mean sorry the
bills completed a fourth and 16 to go up
fourth and 16 touchdown pass chief score
again and then buffalo scores another
touchdown they have a minute left they
score another touchdown with 13 seconds
left game should be over the chiefs
drive 50-plus yards in 13 seconds kick a
field goal to tie the game and then win
it in overtime fun it is legitimately
the craziest [ __ ] game i've ever seen
in my life it was unreal watching that
unbelievable and i feel so bad and this
is what sucks about
a game like football as opposed to
basketball
josh allen the quarterback of the bills
obviously he's playing in the same
conference as scott patrick mahomes
who's the [ __ ] best player in the
league right now they can never get past
the chiefs he played a perfect game he
threw
four or five touchdowns in this game
scrambled his ass off i don't think he
threw a pick i don't remember seeing an
interception played a perfect game
scored what should be a game-winning
touchdown with 13 seconds left and you
should finally say yo i slayed the
dragon we got past him can you imagine
game seven kings
lakers
oh yeah it was like that yeah but he
hadn't he didn't imagine he didn't miss
a single free throw imagine he's chris
webber and he went perfect from the
field and played a flawless game was 10
for 10 didn't have any turnovers and
then still lost because everybody else
[ __ ] up that's what it's like and i
don't know how you recover from that
and that's where i'm like i'm [ __ ]
heartbroken dude as a sports fan you
want to see guys achieve things yeah
like as great as mahomes is you would
love to see this guy get one at least
and i think this was his shot and it's
done like mentally i don't think he's
young but mentally i don't think you get
past that why what
yeah what are you talking about because
you didn't do anything wrong yeah but
you had the you had the team you had the
their offensive coordinator is the maybe
the best in the league he's going to get
a head coaching job so you're going to
lose this guy who called great plays who
helped you develop a ton as a
quarterback right you did everything
perfectly you had the [ __ ] best
player one of the best players in
history when it's all said and done
probably on the ropes he was done
you you did everything you could and
then you still couldn't win i think
you're looking at that like i was
perfect and still lost i the way i look
at that is in a game specifically like
football you can only be responsible for
what you do yeah okay so
if you like just like like uh what's ago
brady it's like i think brady's
incredibly upset that he lost but
he's not they didn't lose because of
what he did yeah i mean you could say
yeah you should have scored more points
it is on you but like josh allen put his
team in position win and his defense
lost it for him right if he threw the
pick and coaching also what they did
they were again rushing four people
which is not a blitz on patrick mahomes
but like dude rush two or three people
who gives a [ __ ] about sacking him cover
tyree kill cover jason kelsey or travis
kelsey and don't let them
eat up field that's it just keep
everything short but they were so
terrified from that tyree hill touchdown
earlier that they had people playing too
far back they made the opposite mistake
of the bucks they had people 30 40 yards
downfield they let them gobble up and
then you let two 19 20 yards plays
happen again fuel range whatever 19 and
30 or whatever it was
and that's how and even just like
kicking they so and you know they've
kicked like a touch back didn't take any
time off the clock with the kickoff what
normally teams will do is do like a real
shitty kick like the 20 yard line yeah
let some fat ass linemen try to run it
back yeah and then waste four seconds
yeah you got the best player in the
world on the other side playing
quarterback take every second off you
can yeah so he got [ __ ] by coaching he
got [ __ ] by his defense he did
everything perfectly and everybody else
failed
hey stefan diggs who i love last year
there was this cool thing when they lost
to the chiefs and the championship game
he stayed on the field and watched him
celebrate as like i want to remember how
shitty this feels and i'm getting that
next year yeah the guy had one catch for
seven yards this game oh so he he stunk
it up another receiver four touchdowns
he could be upset but josh allen is a is
a household name yeah
he's a superstar yeah everyone
i mean espn was saying like everyone was
ready to say he's tom brady and then
they forgot mahomes is mahomes yeah so
all he is is like you're snapping the
homes yes maybe i know but everything
else you're perfect and you are now a
household name his legacy went up for
sure yeah i worry that if i don't know
when they get this chance i mean my my
guys hit me in the group chat and
they're basically like oh yeah this is
uh brady and manning now like this is
the one two in the league and the fact
that we're looking at josh allen as a
two when he wasn't even mentioned in the
conversation before this game
i think is a huge bump and he's gonna
get that self-esteem boost from
everybody recognizing how it's a great
game i mean he even said something
interesting uh in response to the
decision he's like listen you know it
sucks to lose because i guess in the in
uh
overtime it's just first person who
scores a touchdown if it's field goal it
goes back and forth yeah but uh so he
goes looks it sucks that we lost but if
we were in their position we scored we
would have won so you can be annoyed by
the rules but right if we'd won we'd be
incredibly happy with them so i thought
that was like a really measured take
especially right afterwards like
normally people would be like clamoring
to change the rules and this is unfair
and give us a chance to go back and yada
yada yada but i think that i think his
confidence will just be bolstered like
him and mahomes also have a similar
thing that i think brady has and not a
lot of quarterbacks have it i don't
think rogers has it where like
the whole [ __ ] team loves them yeah
like everybody on the team loves mahomes
and i'm seeing josh allen after that
touchdown that should have won the game
[ __ ] going nuts with his linemen just
like let's [ __ ] go yeah like he's the
fiery one and that's cool to see that
because you don't often see that like
manning was a [ __ ] machine like a
computer but i didn't see a lot of his
players going nuts with him on the
sidelines like he's the [ __ ] that's
their boy that's a rare thing so it will
be cool if they
and joe burrows another one in that
conference and this other guy justin
herbert could be good like really good
but that's gonna be fun as [ __ ] but i do
hope he gets one and i i think mahomes
is so goddamn good it doesn't really
matter if you can give him adequate
blocking nobody can beat him so what is
your prediction
i think the chiefs are going to win it
if they get adequate blocking i think
i think i think the rams will win
against the 49ers i think the 49ers beat
the packers because the weather was so
shitty it kind of nullified aaron
rodgers right and i think also a lot of
people are gonna have takes about how
aaron rodgers isn't good and that's
gonna be fun but like i was looking into
some some stats he's without his super
bowl run he's seven and nine in the
playoffs even with it he's eleven and
nine which isn't that great yeah without
mike mccarthy who everybody thought is
the problem and i don't think he's a
good coach he's two and three in the
playoffs like this guy has not produced
at a high level in the playoffs i think
the main problem is when it's [ __ ]
freezing cold the ball is like a brick
throwing it is harder catching it is
harder everything is harder so if you're
the best quarterback in the league
arguably one of the best of all time
yeah you don't want to be playing in
[ __ ] minus 20 degree weather yeah you
want to be in a nice dome so where do
you think
indianapolis is probably going to make a
run i think this people say he's going
to go to denver or carolina which would
be fun denver denver is a little cold i
would like to see him in new orleans
i don't know if peyton is going to stay
there's rumors their coach might leave
but if they would just pony up if they
could whatever picks and they're way
over the cap all the time but just make
it work i would love to see aaron
rodgers and sean payton i would love to
see that ooh interesting yeah that would
be fun i guess the only reason i said
denver is because elwood's no way yeah i
was going to go after him heavy they're
probably gonna smart money says that's
where he'll go and then carolina may
because their owner is like new and
aggressive and it's the coach's last
chance to stay who i thought was gonna
be good but he doesn't seem to be matt
rule he's like if he doesn't produce
this here he's fired right so they're
gonna probably throw a ton of [ __ ] at
green bay and say let's take aaron
rodgers off your hands but i would
personally love to see indianapolis
because their coach is good and it's a
dome and their defense is good and the
run game is good or new orleans just
because it's sean payton and the defense
is great